le troisième des grands au petit morin
c'est pas trés qu'il a 16 ans c'est en
ruines
comment peut-on concilier le métier de
jeunes acteurs et de et d'étudiants quoi
c'est facile aux russes
c'est facile de toute manière il faut
avoir des répétiteurs nous et quand on
loue parcourant le rattrape automatique
loire
m à méditer c'est un droit strict que
personne au monde ne peux m'empêcher
d'exercer toujours un truc c'est très
très très très mauvais parce qu'on n'a
pas répété ça finit par devenir un peu
meilleur je suis vachement ne l'est pas
ce que les gens pensent à force de jouer
devant les gens ont fini par trouver tes
états d'âme comme également la botte
critiques qui sont venus qui nous ont
massacrés au départ du tour étant on
alterne se remette sur une canne une
bonne méditation demande pour être
profitable
une sorte d'état de grâce il a une
double occlusion intra duodénal par
suite de perforation sous pancréatiques
en étoile avec éclatement dernière d'où
épanchements de matières fécales et
adhérence au péritoine d'un pliage
accordéon suspect vraisemblablement du
papier hygiénique
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce merdier
et quand tu seras grand quelle est la
profession que tu désires exercer
opérateurs effectivement c'est une
profession parallèle à celle de comédien
oui aussi